le feu a pris vers 6h ce matin dans
cette grande bâtisse 10 jeunes femmes
étaient à l'intérieur elle dormmait
après avoir fêté l'enterrement de V
jeunes filles de l'une d'ell toutes ont
réussi à sortir et se sont réfugié chez
ce voisin heur demi un grand coup de
sonnette je monte à l'étage pour
regarder par une fenêtre et je vois tout
ce monde sur la
route jeunes femmes en fait oui toutes
ces jeunes femmes toutes toutes toutes
très très très choqué
particulièrement éprouvée l'une des
jeunes femmes enceinte une autre a sauté
du premier étage et souffre du dos
toutes ont par ailleurs été légèrement
intoxiqué par les fumées elles ont été
pris en charge par le Samu et transporté
à l'hôpital les pompiers rapidement sur
place et en nombre ont réussi à limiter
les dégâts matériels dans l'habitation
alors on a eu à faire à départ
d'incendie dans une maison de 150 m²
environ avec un étage
10 personnes étaient rassemblé dans
cette maison hier soir pour
fêter une un enterrement de vie de jeune
fille et puis elles ont été accommodé
par les fumé donc on a pris les 10
personnes en charge une enquête est en
cours le feu pourrait être d'origine
électrique mais cela reste à
confirmer